on croit qu'un adolescent fait un peu
n'importe quoi mais en fait il prend
moins de risques quand l'adulte et donc
du coup quand on lui dit va te faire
vacciner pour les autres donc on te
demande une contribution altruiste aux
biens publics en fait vous fait que la
population soit soient vaccinés il est
tiraillé entre de comportement d'un côté
je voudrais aller me faire vacciner
parce que je suis justement je fais
partie de cette population là qui fait
des efforts altruiste la plupart du
temps mais de l'autre côté en fait je
suis victime de ce qu'on appelle un
biais guy média tu t'es le biais de
d'immédiateté s'est coincé quand fait
mes préférences temporelles fonctionne
pas de manière constante même si je
m'engage aujourd'hui à prendre des
décisions responsables pour demain
demande quand viendra le jour où il faut
que je prenne cette décision là en fait
je ne serais pas capable de me tenir en
mai à mes engagements et donc ce que je
suis en train de dire c'est que encore
une fois je jojo mais le problème en
place il faut pas aller dire à
l'adolescent va te faire vacciner faut
aller dire aux parents va aller faire
vacciner vos enfants parce que
l'adolescent il va être d'une part aux
victimes de ces biais là que je viens de
citer
et d'autre part il va il va porter sur
ses épaules une responsabilité qui n'est
pas la sienne
ce qu'il faut convaincre d'aller se
faire vacciner eux mêmes et d'aller
faire vacciner leurs enfants sont les
adultes et encore une fois donc on a des
manières douces ou pour essayer de les
faire vacciner
on peut aller bien sûr jusqu'à
l'obligation qu'on vous le disiez tout à
l'heure mais en fait ça veut dire qu'en
gros modifié l' architecture de choix et
qu'on passe c'est un nouveau type
d'intervention publique en fait sur
lequel on va on va être ici si on passe
vraiment sur une obligation pas sur un
autre type d'intervention publique mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça serait quand
même dangereux d'euros pourtant
l'obligation de la vaccination sur les
épaules des adolescentes parce que quand
vous avez dit ce sont des individus qui
ont qui ont souffert de cette crise qui
en sont sortis avec des séquelles et on
va pas le refaire en plus porter la
responsabilité du fait qu'on n'a pas
attendre l'immunité collective et donc
je pense qu'il faut retourner le
problème et se concentrait plus sur les
parents il ya tous ces gens là qui sont
indécis
c'est eux qu'il faut convaincre d'aller
se faire vacciner avant
[Musique]